Herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, zu dem Podcast Dicke Bretter.
Ich freue mich ganz besonders, dass ich heute hier Herrn Thomas Zertig und Herrn
Robert Riemann begrüßen kann, die uns helfen wollen,
ein bisschen über ein bestimmtes Amt in Europa zu sprechen, was eine wichtige
Funktion hat und zu erklären,
was da eigentlich praktisch getan wird und was wichtige Themen sind.
Aber bevor Sie das tun und ich ein bisschen was sage zu unseren Gästen,
will ich nochmal sagen, was Dicke Bretter macht.
Wir versuchen in unserem Podcast Dicke Bretter politische Prozesse zu erklären.
Wir versuchen politische Willensbildung transparent zu machen.
Wir versuchen zum Beispiel auch zu erklären, wie entstehen Gesetze,
wie holt man sich Experten in die Parlamente.
Und in dieser Reihe wollen wir heute
sprechen über den europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten und seine Aufgaben.
Und generell so, was macht eigentlich dieses Amt und was macht es nicht?
Und dafür habe ich eben die beiden Herren hier, Robert und Thomas,
die beide beim Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten arbeiten und uns Einblicke
in ihre Arbeit geben wollen.
Dafür will ich mich schon mal sehr bedanken und außerdem möchte ich mich bedanken
beim Europäischen Parlament, denn
wir sitzen hier in der Vertretung des Europäischen Parlaments in Berlin,
in Mitte unter den Linden, die uns freundlicherweise Räume zur Verfügung gestellt
haben und wollen auch darauf hinweisen, dass es hier unter den Linden eine Ausstellung
gibt über das Europäische Parlament und über die Europäische Kommission,
die man sich ansehen kann.
Ich habe die selber auch schon mal angeschaut. Die ist sehr lehrreich,
kann man eine Menge in relativ kurzer Zeit lernen über diese beiden europäischen Institutionen.
Und jetzt legen wir mal los. Wir beginnen mit Thomas.
Thomas, sag doch mal, was machst du beim europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
und was qualifiziert dich für diesen Job?
Guten Morgen, Konstanze. Danke für die Einleitung.
Erstmal vielleicht vorweg, was ist der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte?
Das erklärt er nämlich, was sich da machen. Der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte
ist die unabhängige Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde für die EU-Organe und Einrichtungen.
Was sind EU-Organe und Einrichtungen? Das sind eben zum Beispiel das Europäische Parlament,
die Europäische Kommission, wir selbst als europäischer Datenschutzbeauftragter
oder eben auch Einrichtungen wie Europol. Und was machen wir da?
Wir überwachen die Datenverarbeitung dieser EU-Organe und Einrichtungen.
Wir bearbeiten Beschwerden von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern, führen Untersuchungen
durch und entscheiden dazu. Und das ist meine derzeitige Aufgabe.
Ich bin Leiter des Referates Aufsicht und Durchsetzung und mache genau das mit
meinem Team, dass wir eben überprüfen, ob die EU-Organe und Einrichtungen die
Datenschutzvorschriften auch einhalten,
die sie ja von den anderen verlangen.
Sind das typischerweise Juristen oder wie setzen sich so diese Leute im Team zusammen?
In meinem Team sind wir alle Juristen, bis auf eine Person.
Wir sind ungefähr 30 Mitarbeiter, die ich in dem Team habe.
Und es sind alles Juristen. Warum sind das alles Juristen? Ich denke, das ist klar.
Datenschutz ist im Kern Grundrechtsschutz. Und deswegen, da wir Entscheidungen
vorbereiten, die der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte dann erlässt,
brauchen wir juristische Abwägungen.
Wir brauchen Abwägungen und Prüfungen von Rechtsgrundlagen, Zweckbundung,
Verhältnismäßigkeit, solche Sachen.
Denn alles das, was der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte entscheidet,
Kann auch vor Gericht überprüft werden. Und daher brauchen wir die Juristen,
die da sicherstellen, dass das so ist.
Das ist ja auch bei den nationalen Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden oder generell
auch bei betrieblichen Datenschutzbeauftragten auch üblich, dass einfach viele
Juristen da arbeiten, weil es eben verrechtlich fällt.
Jetzt frage ich mal Robert. Robert arbeitet auch beim europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Was machst du denn da und was qualifiziert dich denn?
Hallo erstmal, ich bin Robert und ich arbeite beim Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
im Referat Technik und Privatheit.
Anders als in dem Referat von Thomas ist es so,
dass wir hier nur einen Juristen haben, der zeitweise unserem Team momentan
hilft und ansonsten Ingenieure und Data Breach Notifications.
Thomas, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wie wir das im deutschen Jargon sagen.
Und das ist auch etwas, was wir im Vorfeld schon einmal angesprochen haben.
Dadurch, dass wir international hauptsächlich auf Englisch uns da miteinander kommunizieren,
ist es so, dass wir im Alltag kaum die deutschen Fachworte benutzen,
wenn wir uns nicht gerade mit deutschen Kollegen austauschen.
Und das bringt mich persönlich in diese Bedrängnis, dass mir da teilweise die Vokabeln fehlen.
Ich habe auch, das kann ich zu meiner Geschichte sagen, auch nicht vorher in
der deutschen Behörde gearbeitet, sondern habe gleich in Brüssel angefangen.
Aber ich glaube, wir werden mit den rechtlichen englischen Begriffen klarkommen.
Die kriegen wir schon übersetzt oder zumindest verständlich gemacht.
Jetzt habt ihr schon ein bisschen eure Themengrößen angesprochen.
Wie viele Menschen arbeiten, vielleicht kann Thomas jetzt sagen,
insgesamt beim europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, wenn man jetzt so alle Teams betrachtet?
Insgesamt sind wir ungefähr 120 Mitarbeiter.
Das klingt viel, ist es aber nicht, weil ungefähr die Hälfte davon beim Europäischen
Datenschutzausschuss arbeiten.
Das ist was anderes. Das ist eine andere Einrichtung. Der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss
ist durch die DSGVO, die Datenschutzgrundverordnung,
eingerichtet worden und koordiniert praktisch die Ansichten aller Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden
in der Europäischen Union.
Und da gibt es ein Sekretariat und die Kollegen arbeiten in dem Sekretariat.
Ich glaube, über den Ausschuss werden wir vielleicht später nochmal ein bisschen
detaillierter sprechen.
Jetzt will ich mal ein bisschen über den Kopf der Behörde reden.
In Deutschland ist es ja häufig so, dass die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten,
manchmal sogar die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten, aber vor allen Dingen die
Amtsträger im Bund, die sind ziemlich bekannt oder zumindest vergleichsweise bekannt.
Zum Beispiel jemand wie Peter Schaar oder Ulrich Kelber.
Die waren sehr oft in den Medien vertreten.
Das heißt, es gibt eine relativ laute Stimmung für den Datenschutz.
Aber die haben ja auch eine andere Funktion.
Derzeit haben wir Frau Specht Riemenschneider hier in Deutschland.
Auch die hat noch eine Menge Interviews gemacht, als ihr Amt begann.
Wie ist denn das in Europa? Ich meine, die Aufgaben des Amtsträgers sind ja
anders. Wie bekannt ist der Amtsträger?
Und würdet ihr auch sagen, ist er eine laute Stimme für den Datenschutz oder
arbeitet er eigentlich eher im Hintergrund? Vielleicht Thomas.
Ich würde sagen, das kommt darauf an. Also unser derzeitiger,
der derzeitige europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte, Herr Wojcik-Wiwirovski,
ist eigentlich ziemlich bekannt hier in Brüssel.
Und das erklärt sich natürlich auch aus dem Aufgabenzuschnitt.
Der wichtigste Unterschied zwischen dem europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
und den nationalen Aufsichtsbehörden ist eben die Zuständigkeit.
Der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte ist eben ausschließlich zuständig für
die EU-Organe und Einrichtungen, also für die öffentliche Verwaltung der Europäischen Union.
Daher kennt man ihn vielleicht etwas weniger in den Mitgliedstaaten,
aber er ist gleichberechtigtes Mitglied im europäischen Datenschutzausschuss,
wo sich eben alle dann treffen.
Also Herr Wieworowski trifft sich regelmäßig mit Frau Specht-Riemenschneider zum Beispiel.
Von daher, wenn es Entscheidungen gibt, die der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte
trifft, zum Beispiel gegen die Europäische Kommission oder zum Beispiel gegen Europol.
Da sind wir natürlich schon im Vordergrund, würde ich sagen.
Also von daher sehe ich den Unterschied nicht sehr groß im Vergleich zu den Mitgliedstaaten.
Zumal ja auch in Europa der Datenschutzbeauftragte oft konsultiert wird,
zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung, wenn es um geplante Gesetze geht oder wenn
es um die angesprochenen Institutionen und deren Evaluierung geht.
Also er gibt ja auch öffentliche Stellungnahmen ab.
Wie häufig kommt das, sagen wir mal, im Jahr vor?
Also wie häufig wendet sich der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte an die Öffentlichkeit
mit Stellungnahmen zu den Fragen in seinem Geschäftsbereich ungefähr?
Ich würde sagen, quasi wöchentlich. Warum ist das so?
Weil das ist, glaube ich, sehr unterschiedlich im Vergleich zur nationalen Ebene.
Die Europäische Kommission ist verpflichtet, den europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
zu konsultieren. immer dann, wenn es neue Rechtsakte gibt, die von der Kommission
vorbereitet werden, die personenbezogene Daten betreffen.
Und das kannst du dir vorstellen, das ist relativ breit. Das ist heute fast
immer der Fall, egal ob Digitalisierung, Sicherheit, Migration,
Gesundheit, KI, Plattformregulierung, internationale Verträge.
Und da kommt dann der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte ins Spiel und dann
gibt er eben Stellungnahme oder Kommentare ab, die wir dann veröffentlichen.
Und das wird immer mehr.
Jetzt haben wir schon ein paar Themen gehört, da werden wir vielleicht nachher
nochmal ins Detail gehen, aber alle diese Themen haben eine gewisse technische
Komponente mittlerweile.
Also alle Datenschutzfragen verbinden sich mit Technikfragen.
Was macht ihr als Unterstützung oder kannst du mal vielleicht an einem Beispiel machen, Robert?
Was macht ihr, um eine kompetente, informierte Stellungnahme sozusagen mit technischem Wissen zu bereichern?
Wie stelle ich mir das Zusammenhang mit den Juristen vor?
Also es gibt verschiedene Referate beim EDPS. Thomas hatte schon sein Referat
angesprochen, dann gibt es das Referat Technik und Privatheit und dann gibt
es noch das Referat Policy.
Und wenn jetzt ein neuer Gesetzesakt vorbereitet wird und dazu auch formell
die Meinung eingeholt werden muss, die Stellungnahme vom Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten,
dann wird das durch dieses andere Referat koordiniert.
Und die schauen dann in dem Haus, wer hat dann die Kompetenzen, um das zu unterstützen.
Und sobald klar wird, dass es tatsächlich etwas sehr technisches und das wurde
so auch von dieser Abteilung noch nicht bearbeitet,
dann gibt es eine Anfrage an das Referat Technik, Technologie und Privatheit,
eine Person zur Unterstützung zu benennen.
Und diese Person arbeitet dann gleichberechtigt mit diesen Anwälten,
den Juristen zusammen an dieser Stellungnahme.
Und da schauen dann auch nochmal die Referatsleiter aus dem Referat Technologie
ebenso drüber, ob das alles fundiert ist und so rausgehen kann.
Sie legen mir jetzt schon eher vor, wie klassische eigentlich wissenschaftliche
Arbeiten, Techniker gründen, Technikfolgen abschätzen und so in der Art.
Also gibst du Zusammenarbeit mit akademischen Forschern? Ist das typisch oder
Sachverständigen, die man sich dazu holt?
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht können wir da nochmal einen Punkt zu machen,
weil wir über den Europäischen Datenschutzausschuss im Detail sprechen.
Ich selber habe nicht den Eindruck, dass für diese Situation,
die ich gerade ausgesucht habe, externe Expertise einen spezifischen,
konkreten Fall hinzugezogen wird. Aber natürlich ist das so,
dass die Leute recherchieren.
Und bevor der Vorschlag der Kommission auf den Tisch kommt, sind das natürlich
häufig Themen, die schon in der Breite, in der Öffentlichkeit angesprochen wurden,
wo sich vorher schon Forscher oder auch EDRI,
das sind Interessenverbände in Brüssel. Ich muss mal kurz erklären.
Was ist EDRI? Kannst du sagen, was EDRI ist? Sonst sage ich es.
Du kannst es bestimmt besser.
Das ist eine NGO, Nichtregierungsorganisation, die heißt European Digital Rights
und die verbindet sehr viele nationale Digitalrechtsorganisationen und versucht
sozusagen auch die Policy und politische Entscheidungsprozesse in Brüssel Elffluss zu nehmen.
Also relativ bekannt in Datenschutzkreisen, aber darüber hinaus vielleicht nicht so.
Genau, und die haben dann auch ihre eigenen Stellungnahmen und die werden natürlich gelesen.
Und insofern gibt es natürlich schon einen Einfluss, was außerhalb des Büros
passiert, auf das, was intern diskutiert wird.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte für den Fall
einer Beantwortung dieser Anfragen der Kommission für eine Stellungnahme einmal
die Meinung von Idr. explizit einholen würde.
Aber quasi ist es eine Zusammenarbeit von technischen oder Abteilungen,
jedenfalls die sich mit bestimmten Techniken beschäftigen, natürlich mit den
notwendigen Juristen, die dann die Einschätzung über die Grundrechte machen. Korrekt? Okay.
Jetzt gibt es ja gerade eine besondere Situation. Da sollten wir vielleicht
erstmal kurz darüber sprechen, wie der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte benannt wird.
Es gibt ja ein formelltes Auswahlverfahren und ist oft bekannt.
Und diesmal ist aber eine Situation entstanden, die es so noch nicht in Europa
gab, denn der derzeitige Amtsinhaber ist schon eigentlich lange über seiner
typischen Länge der Amtszeit,
nämlich diese fünf Jahre, die hat schon, wenn ich jetzt recht in Erinnerung
habe, am 5. Dezember letzten Jahres geändert.
Aber es gab die Situation, dass sich der EU-Rat und das EU-Parlament nicht sozusagen
im Einvernehmen auf einen neuen Kandidaten
geeinigt haben, sondern zu unterschiedlichen Voten gekommen sind.
Vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal, vielleicht warst du gerade Thomas,
ein bisschen sagen, wie typischerweise verläuft das Auswahlverfahren und warum
es diesmal zu diesem merkwürdigen Deadlock gekommen ist und was man jetzt machen kann.
Ja, ganz einfach. Die Datenschutzgrundverordnung für die EU-Organe,
mit der wir arbeiten, die regelt das und die regelt eben, dass der europäische
Datenschutzbeauftragte, wie du schon gesagt hast, Konstanze,
eine Amtszeit von normalerweise fünf Jahren hat und dann zu benennen ist im
Einvernehmen zwischen dem Europäischen Parlament und den Mitgliedstaaten im Rat der EU.
Und wie das läuft, ist nach Ablauf der Amtszeit erstellt die Europäische Kommission,
macht die Europäische Kommission eine Ausschreibung, da kann sich dann jeder bewerben.
Dann werden die Bewerber von der Europäischen Kommission geprüft und dann verabschiedet
und veröffentlicht die Europäische Kommission eine Liste von Kandidaten.
Und aufgrund dieser Liste oder von dieser Liste müssen sich dann das Parlament
und der Rat entscheiden.
Und wie du das schon gesagt hast, diesmal haben sie sich noch nicht entscheiden können.
Das ist nicht neu, das gab es schon mal.
Ja, das gab es vorher schon mal. Leider.
Aber es ist jetzt zu sagen, das macht nichts, ist übertrieben.
Aber die EU-DSGVO, also die Datenschutzgrundverordnung für die EU-Organe,
die sagt, solange es eben keinen neuen gibt, bleibt der Alte im Amt,
der Amtsinhaber, und hat alle Rechten und Pflichten.
Und es geht dann weiter business as usual.
Also solange die sich nicht einigen, macht der jetzige Amtshörer einfach weiter.
Hm, ist das quasi eine unendliche Frist? Das heißt, wenn die sich niemals einigen,
dann bleibt er einfach für immer im Amt.
Das klingt für mich jetzt rechtlich auch nicht normal.
Oder gibt es da irgendeine Frist, die bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt eine Einigung bestehen muss?
Nein, gibt es nicht. Gibt keine Frist. Das sieht die Verordnung nicht vor.
Und wenn der Amtsnämmchen Lust mehr hat?
Das sieht die Vorordnung noch nicht vor.
Ich möchte dazu sagen, dass das auch kein europäischer Sonderfall ist,
sondern diese Situation gibt es natürlich auch an den Mitgliedsländern.
Ich denke da in Spanien, wo es auch Schwierigkeiten gab, ein neues Mandat zu verabschieden.
Und auch in einigen Bundesländern, in Deutschland, gab es lange Zeit Unklarheit, wer das Mandat bekommt.
Insofern ist das leider etwas, was man in Europa häufiger beobachten muss.
Und natürlich würden sich die Mitarbeiter wünschen, dass alles immer sofort entscheiden wird.
Das ist natürlich die Idee, aber in dem Fall, wo das zurzeit beim europäischen
Datenschutzbeauftragten das nicht sofort klappt, werden die Geschäfte weitergeführt.
Aber ich nehme jetzt so ein bisschen aus der Art, wie ihr das sagt,
dass es auch nicht wirklich ein riesen Problem ist oder zumindest mit einer
gewissen Gelassenheit darauf blickt, dass es sich eben ein Jahr hinzieht,
meine Güte. Ist nicht so schlimm, richtig?
Na, schlimm nicht, unschön ist es.
Okay, also würdet ihr, ich frage es mal Thomas vielleicht, würdet ihr einen
Tipp abgeben, wie sich dieser Deadlock auflösen wird oder was es da für eine
Vorstellung gibt, wann sich diese beiden Institutionen vielleicht einigen können
oder was sagen denn die Auguren?
Ja, die Auguren sagen derzeit nichts.
Da können wir nichts zu sagen, weil es wirklich in der Hand vom Parlament ist und vom Rat.
Die müssen sich zusammensetzen und eine Lösung finden. Aber wann das passiert, dazu, im nächsten Jahr.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Einzige, was feststeht. Nicht mehr dieses Jahr.
Okay, das ist ja schon mal eine Aussage, oder? 2026 wird es sich entscheiden.
Na gut, ich will jetzt vielleicht mal so einen Beispielfall versuchen zu erklären.
Wir sind ja hier ein klassischer Erklärbär-Podcast, wie das denn so läuft,
wenn der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte tätig wird. Also wir nehmen jetzt
mal ganz umstrittene Beispiel. Wir nehmen vielleicht mal die Chatkontrolle.
Das ist ja seit vielen Jahren umstritten. Wir gehen jetzt ins vierte Jahr.
Vor kurzem ist auch gerade eine gewisse Einigung mit der polnischen Ratspräsidentschaft
in die Wege geleitet worden. Aber mich interessiert es zu sagen,
jetzt mal der Ablauf, wie wird der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte involviert?
Die Kommission hat ja den Vorschlag damals vorgelegt, vor drei Jahren,
vor mehr als drei Jahren.
Wie ist die typische Vorgehensweise, wenn eine Konsultation,
die ja stattfinden muss, beginnt? Thomas vielleicht.
Genau, Konstanze, du hast es schon angesprochen. Die Europäische Kommission
arbeitet ihren Vorschlag aus und bevor sie diesen Vorschlag veröffentlicht,
gibt es eine interne Abstimmung in der Europäischen Kommission.
Und gleichzeitig mit dieser internen Abstimmung werden wir informell auch unterrichtet
und können dann bereits erste kleine Kommentare abgeben und sobald dann die
Kommission ihren Gesetzgebungsvorschlag veröffentlicht hat,
dann leitet sie das dann ganz amtlich dem europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
zu Mit der Bitte um Stellungnahme.
Dann setzen sich die Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus einem anderen Referat hin,
nämlich aus dem Referat Politik und Gesetzgebung und analysieren den Vorschlag
der Kommission und schreiben die Stellungnahme,
die dann vom europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten veröffentlicht wird.
Und mit dieser Stellungnahme ist dann praktisch der Gesetzgeber,
das Parlament und der Rat der EU, die Mitgliedstaaten, die haben dann diese
Stellungnahme und können dann damit arbeiten.
Und damit erschöpft sich dann normalerweise das Offizielle, das Amtliche des
europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Die Stellungnahme ist veröffentlicht und dann war es das.
Aber der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte ist natürlich jederzeit bereit,
dann auch zu Anhörungen zu kommen und vorzutragen, was in dieser Stellungnahme dann drinsteht.
Vielleicht nur noch eine kurze Nachfrage. Wir haben jetzt das Beispiel der Chatkontrolle,
aber wird für jedes dieser Verfahren auch die Stellungnahme öffentlich oder
gibt es auch welche, wo das nicht der Fall ist?
Die Stellungnahmen sind grundsätzlich öffentlich.
Okay, und wird es üblicherweise einfach mal ganz praktisch gefragt,
wird es in Englisch geschrieben und später von anderen übersetzt oder auch mal in anderen Sprachen?
Wie läuft es sozusagen in diesem Sprachengewürr in Brüssel?
Wir arbeiten grundsätzlich auf Englisch und bemühen uns, Zusammenfassungen zumindest
auf Deutsch und auf Französisch herauszugeben.
Und das findest du auf unserer Webseite dann.
Aha. Okay, also nun haben wir sozusagen die Beginn des Prozesses und wir haben gehört,
okay, der Datenschutzbeauftragte steht dann auch den zum Beispiel Parlamentariern
zur Verfügung, wenn er noch Stellungnahmen oder mündliche Anhörungen vielleicht noch mitwirkt.
Aber nun hat ja gerade die Chat-Kontrolle auch neue technische Fragen aufgeworfen.
Da geht es um massenhafte Scannen, da geht es darum, wie zum Beispiel Filter funktionieren.
Wie kommen dann die technischen Abteilungen rein? Also vielleicht sagst du mal,
Robert, wie das in diesem konkreten Fall war.
Also Thomas, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, dann war das hier doch eine gemeinsame
Stellungnahme, oder? Ja.
Vom ETSA und vom Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten?
Genau, zu dem Thema Chat-Controller.
Ja, der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss hat sich dann hinterher eingeklinkt in die Debatte.
Aber das, ja gut, das war aber, ich glaube, am Anfang war es der Europäische
Datenschutzbeauftragte.
Also ist das so, dass es ja diese zwei Stellen gibt es mit der Europäischen
Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Und es gibt den Europäischen Datenschutzausschuss und das Gesetz regelt,
wer die Stellungnahme bearbeitet und dann macht und das ändert auch den Prozess
sozusagen und wenn wir uns jetzt einmal anschauen, wie das ist,
wenn das der EDPS alleine macht.
Dann landet das beim Präparat Politik und dann wird dann gesagt,
okay, das ist ein technisches Thema, das betrifft wahrscheinlich Kryptografie,
und Pseudonyme und dann gibt es die Anfrage an das Reparattechnik.
Das macht dann mein Reparatsleiter, der bekommt das dann auf seinen Schreibtisch
und sagt sich, ja, wir haben hier diese Person, die hat ja schon in den letzten
sechs Jahren zu dem Thema gearbeitet und steckt da gut im Thema.
Die wird jetzt Teil von dem Team.
Und wird dann mitarbeiten und den Juristen Frage und Antwort stehen,
wie die eigene Perspektive, die technische Perspektive dazu aussieht.
Und natürlich ist es so, dass die Person nicht alles weiß. Wir sind in unserer
Technikergruppe ungefähr 15 Leute.
Und in der Technikergruppe müssen wir alle Themen, die was mit Datenschutz zu
tun haben, abdecken können.
Das heißt, zu Pandemiezeiten sind wir alle Corona-Experten gewesen,
haben uns mit Bluetooth-Tokens beschäftigt und dann gibt es die Blockchain-Zeiten,
dann werden wir alle Blockchain-Experten.
So muss man sich das ein bisschen vorstellen. Es ist wirklich breit gefächert.
Insofern ist es so, dass wir natürlich nicht auf dem Niveau Expertise anbieten
können, wie das die Universitäten teilweise können oder auch Spezielle Organisationen,
die nur ein Kernthema haben.
Das bedeutet, dass wir natürlich viel Recherche an und am Schreibtisch machen.
Wir schauen uns ins Internet und wir schauen uns an, wir lesen uns die Reports
durch, die Wissenschaftler zu dem Thema veröffentlicht haben.
Wir lesen auch akademische Papiere zu diesen Themen, um dann sozusagen einen
fundierten Beitrag zu dieser Stellungnahme zusammen mit den Juristen zu erarbeiten.
Und das machen wir alles auf Englisch. Das hatte Thomas schon erwähnt.
Und dann gibt es natürlich einen internen Prozess. Das heißt,
wenn ein Mitarbeiter dann diesen Vorschlag aufgeschrieben hat,
dann ist das natürlich noch nicht sofort die Meinung des europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Das heißt, das geht dann durch die verschiedenen Referate. Und das ist jetzt
aber nur der Fall für eine Stellungnahme, die der EDPR es alleine macht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein guter Moment ist. Thomas, was meinst du dazu zu erklären,
was passiert, wenn auch der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss angehört werden soll?
Ja, das wäre vielleicht auch gerade ein Unterschied, wenn man Prozesswissen
sozusagen mal vergleichen will, vielleicht ein guter Moment zu sagen,
was passiert, wenn man sich gemeinschaftlich äußert.
Ja, ganz einfach. Robert, fang du an und dann springe ich ein.
Super.
In dem Fall ist das so, dass der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte ja Teil
des Europäischen Datenschutzausschusses ist.
Das heißt, der EDPS bringt sich sowieso ein in fast alle Themen,
zu denen der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss gehört wird.
Und dann gibt es sozusagen ein anderes Template für so eine gemeinsame Stellungnahme.
Und dann gibt es ein Mandat von der Sitzung aller Datenschutzkommissare in Europa,
die dann beschließen, wie dieses Thema gehandhabt werden soll intern.
Und dann gibt es beim Europäischen Dutchenschutzausschuss mehrere Fachgruppen.
Die sind auch auf der Webseite gelistet und die haben natürlich alle englische
Namen und die wurden nie in alle EU-Amtssprachen übersetzt.
Insofern gibt es einmal diese berühmte Technology Experts Hub Group.
Das ist die, wo die Techniker.
In der Mehrheit sind. Und ich weiß, wie man das auf Deutsch sagen würde.
Expertengruppe zu Technologiefragen vielleicht.
Und dort dürfen alle Mitgliedsländer, die im Europäischen Datenschutzausschuss
vertreten sind, teilweise auch nur mit einer Beobachterrolle,
eine Person absenden, die dort sich zu Themen einbringen kann. Und dann wird beraten.
Wir haben jetzt das Mandat bekommen, hierzu eine Stellungnahme zu erarbeiten.
Wir brauchen jetzt erstmal ein paar Leute, die hier schriftführend, federführend sind.
Und dann gibt es jemanden oder ein Mitgliedsland, das freiwillig sagt,
okay, wir werden dieses Projekt leiten.
Und dann werden noch ein paar andere Personen gesucht, die mitarbeiten.
Das ist dann sozusagen ein Schreibteam. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das besser auf
Deutsch sagen kann, aber ich glaube, die Idee ist klar.
Und die treffen sich dann alle zwei Wochen mit Hausaufgaben zwischendurch,
um einen ersten Entwurf vorzubereiten.
Und bei technischen Fragen würde,
Ein Thema wahrscheinlich in der Expertengruppe für Technologiefragen natürlich landen.
Das ist natürlich ganz interessant, weil Deutschland in all solchen Fällen eine
Sonderrolle hat, weil es gibt ja nicht nur Mitarbeiter auf dem Niveau vom BFDI,
sondern es gibt ja auch Mitarbeiter in den Länderbehörden.
Und daher gibt es auch sehr viel Expertise und die möchte man natürlich nicht außen vor lassen.
Das bedeutet, dass es dann zusätzlich auch noch einen innerdeutschen Prozess
gibt, der festlegt, wer in welcher Gruppe zu welchem Thema mitarbeitet,
weil es können natürlich nicht alle Ländergruppen auf Europa direkt mitarbeiten.
Und so ist das dann am Ende, dass bei einem Thema zum Beispiel dann ein Technologie-Experte
aus Spanien dabei ist, einer aus Italien, einer aus Hessen und dann vielleicht
noch jemand aus Finnland.
Und die arbeiten dann relativ autonom. Da gibt es natürlich Richtlinien,
wie man erfolgreich so einen Entwurf vorbereitet und stellen dann den Entwurf
zunächst vor in der Expertengruppe für Technologiefragen.
Die trifft sich monatlich und zwar online seit Corona und zweimal im Jahr gibt
es auch einen Pflichtpräsenztermin, sodass man sich ein bisschen kennenlernen kann.
Und dort gibt es dann sozusagen einen Tag, wo dann alle Themen einmal durchgearbeitet
werden inklusive dann auch diesem Entwurf von dem Team, was für den Entwurf
zum Beispiel für Chat-Control zuständig ist.
Und wenn dann die Technologie-Expertgruppe sagt, ja, damit sind wir jetzt super
zufrieden und wir denken, das ist auf jeden Fall mehrheitsfähig,
dann kann das auch dem Plenarmeeting mit allen Kommissaren vorgelegt werden,
die das theoretisch verabschieden könnten.
Aber bei sehr komplexen Fragen sagt man sich, vielleicht wollen wir doch auch
noch mehr juristische Perspektive drin haben.
Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass in der Technologie, in der Expertengruppe zu
Technologiefragen auch Juristen sitzen.
Also es sind auch Leute, die teilweise beides studiert haben.
Einen Ingenieurabschluss und möglicherweise einen Abschluss im Jura.
Und dann kann das dann teilweise so sein, dass auch noch andere Expertengruppen
konsultiert werden, bevor das schließlich das Plenar-Meeting erreicht.
Gibt es noch etwas, was du da ergänzen würdest, Thomas?
Das klingt alles sehr kompliziert, würde ich sagen, aber ist es eigentlich nicht.
Aber es ist eben ein typisches Beispiel, wie Europa zusammenarbeitet,
weil, das hat Robert ja schon wunderschön erklärt, in diesen Expertengruppen
sitzen eben Vertreter aller Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden aus ganz Europa.
Ja, Italien, Spanien, Finnland, Deutschland und so weiter.
Und das heißt, da werden täglich Kompromisse geschmiedet, Ansichten ausgetauscht
und eben auch versucht, eine einheitliche Auslegung in diesen Datenschutzfragen
zu finden. Und das ist ganz spannend.
Es gibt ja eine gewisse Kritik an diesem Datenschutz-Ausschuss,
auch schon seit langem, eigentlich schon in der Vorgängergruppe,
die sich damals noch Artikel 20 Gruppe nannte,
nämlich einfach genau diese Komplexität und teilweise auch langfristigen Prozesse,
die einfach für so einen Konsens, glaube ich, dazugehören.
Aber das ist natürlich auch eine typische Kritik von Menschen,
die eben sehr schnell irgendwie ein Ergebnis wollen und dann nicht gut damit
klarkommen, dass sehr viele Nationen sich da einigen müssen.
Wie seht ihr diese Kritik? Vielleicht Thomas mal. Ihr kennt die sicher, oder?
Die Kritik kenne ich. Die gibt es seit über 20 Jahren.
Vorher wurde sich beschwert, dass die alte Artikel 29 Gruppe unverbindliche
Stellungnahmen abgibt, an die man sich dann halten muss.
Und das wurde immer beklagt. Jetzt ist es eigentlich umgekehrt.
Jetzt ist der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss, der natürlich immer noch Stellungnahmen
abgibt, der aber inzwischen verbindliche Entscheidungen trifft gegenüber anderen,
den eigenen Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden und nun wird auch das wieder beklagt.
Also wie man es macht, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, wir haben uns in Europa im
Positiven weiterentwickelt.
Wir haben die DSGVO für deren einheitliche Anwendung der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss
an der Arbeit ist und das hat sich jetzt eingespielt und ich denke,
da kommen die Entscheidungen auch relativ schnell.
Ja, jetzt habt ihr beide die Datenschutzgrundverordnung schon mehrfach angesprochen.
Ich will vielleicht mal ganz grob zusammenfassen, was das ist.
Das ist also im Prinzip ein EU-Gesetz, also das Wirkung entfaltet in allen Ländern,
das sozusagen die Grundrechte zur,
was man in Deutschland informationelle Selbstbestimmung nennt, regelt.
Und nun ist es ja so, zumindest aus meiner Sicht ist es so, es war so ein gewisser Moment in time.
Es gab eine bestimmte Situation, politische Situationen, wo es möglich war,
die Datenschutzgrundverordnung tatsächlich zum Gesetz werden zu lassen.
Und aus meiner Sicht sind diese Zeiten vorbei. Denn heute wird,
glaube ich, der Datenschutz ein bisschen anders betrachtet.
Und das kann man vielleicht auch gerade sehr aktuell sehen an dem sogenannten
digitalen Omnibus, also dass versucht wird, die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung
ein bisschen zu verändern.
Und zwar in Zeiten, wo der Datenschutz vielleicht nicht gerade ein hippes Thema
ist, sondern zumindest auch in Deutschland sehr häufig als Innovationsbremse
gesehen wird, zumindest von der aktuellen Regierung.
Wie seht ihr, ich frage das mal jetzt ganz allgemein, vielleicht Thomas zuerst,
diese Datenschutz-Grundverordnung und die Bedeutung, die sie in der Gruppe hat?
Und was haltet ihr von den Vorschlägen, die jetzt im digitalen Omnibus besprochen werden?
Ein schönes Thema, Konstanze, weil ich vor meiner Zeit beim Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
bei der Europäischen Kommission gearbeitet habe und da im Referat Datenschutz
und einer derjenigen war,
die die DSGVO mitgeschrieben hat.
Also ein Datenschutzheld.
Ja, ein EU-Beamter, der im Datenschutz tätig ist.
Nee, Konstanze, man muss doch
einfach nochmal gucken, wieso reden wir über den Datenschutz in Europa?
Weil die europäische Grundrechtekarte, praktisch die Verfassung von Europa,
den Datenschutz ausdrücklich als Grundrecht stützt.
Und das ist eine feste Sache, an der man nicht vorbeikommt.
Und die Auswirkung dieses Grundrechts ist, dass die EU eben verpflichtet ist
und den Mitgliedstaaten ebenso,
dieses Grundrecht zu schützen und Regeln dafür zu schaffen, wie man das am besten
macht und das hat die Europäische Union schon seit 1995 gemacht und es gibt
jetzt eben seit 2016 die Datenschutzgrundverordnung,
die das auch eben versucht, um zu sagen was sind die regeln um
mit personenbezogenen daten umzugehen und wenn man sich das anguckt das ist
die erste große der erste große eu-rechtsakt der im digitalen feld spielt und
das ist schon ein meilenstein würde ich sagen das ist ja jetzt die
Klar, jetzt haben wir den, hast du erwähnt, Konstanze, den digitalen Omnibus,
der versucht, an dem Text der Datenschutzgrundveränderung Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass man sagen kann, das Ganze wird infrage gestellt.
Es gibt nicht, weil die EU-Grundrechte-Karte diesen Schutz des Grundrechts Datenschutz einfordert.
Also das heißt, an den Grundprinzipien kann schon deswegen nicht gesägt werden,
weil ja sozusagen die EU-Karte darüber steht. Und übrigens auch die Europäische
Menschenrechtskonvention.
Okay, das heißt, ich sehe da gar keinen Alarmismus oder Angst vor den neuen
Regeln, die da kommen können?
Oder gibt es da auch eine Kritik dran?
Na ja, sag mal so, dass der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss und der Europäische
Datenschutzbeauftragte, wir arbeiten gerade an einer großen Stellungnahme für
diesen digitalen Omnibus.
Aber der Witz an der Sache ist, dass es einen Änderungsvorschlag der Kommission
gibt, der an der Begriffsbestimmung, was ist überhaupt ein personenbeziehendes
Datum, versucht, was zu ändern.
Und die Kommission behauptet, das ist, was sie da vorschlägt,
der Text ist einfach nur eine Übernahme eines Gerichtsurteils.
Das Interessante ist, das Gerichtsurteil, auf das sich die Kommission da bezieht,
ist eine Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs in einem Fall,
wo eine europäische Einrichtung, nämlich den Europäischen Einheitlichen Abwicklungsausschuss,
gegen eine Aufsichtsmaßnahme von uns, vom Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, geklagt hatte.
Die waren nicht einverstanden mit einer Anweisung, die wir denen erteilt haben.
Und darüber hat dann eben der Europäische Gerichtshof entschieden.
Aber das Urteil vom Europäischen Gerichtshof ist eben nicht eins zu eins umgesetzt
jetzt worden durch die Kommission, sondern die Kommission hat das Gerichtsurteil
ein bisschen anders ausgelegt und hat dann eben einen neuen Text vorgeschlagen,
wie Sie das verstehen.
Aber da kann ich jetzt schon sagen,
wir sehen das anders. Wir haben das Gerichtsurteil anders verstanden.
Und das wird auch Teil unserer Stellungnahme sein zu diesem digitalen Omnibus.
Also die ist ja noch nicht öffentlich, falls, da ja der Podcast erst im Januar
2016 erscheinen wird, die dann öffentlich ist, werden wir den natürlich verlinken.
Da kommen wir gleich zu einer Frage, die sich vorhin schon bei mir aufgedrängt
hat, als wir kurz das Beispiel mit der Chat-Kontrolle hatten.
Mal angenommen, da besteht dann eine rechtliche Differenz, dass die Stellungnahme
des europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten sagt, na, so finden wir das nicht korrekt.
Also zum Beispiel in der Interpretation des eben angesprochenen Urteils.
Wie ist denn dann der weitere Verlauf? Kann die EU-Kommission für den Vorschlag,
den sie dann konkret macht, auch einfach ignorieren?
Muss sie bestimmte Elemente aus den Stellungnahmen einbauen?
Also wie ist denn der Prozess danach, wenn die Stellungnahme abgegeben ist?
Kein Mensch ist verpflichtet, uns zuzuhören, um das mal ganz krass zu sagen.
Aber das ist natürlich Expertise und Datenschutzwissen, was wir da herantreten.
Das ist ja die ureigenste Aufgabe einer unabhängigen Datenschutzaufsicht,
dieses Wissen weiterzugeben und sagen, unsere Auslegung, unser Verständnis von
diesem Vorschlag ist wie folgt.
Von daher wissen wir eigentlich schon,
dass sowohl die Kommissionen als auch die Mitgliedstaaten als auch die Abgeordneten
im Europäischen Parlament sehr wohl sich das angucken,
was vom Europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten da geschrieben wird.
Aber rechtlich verbindlich ist das nicht.
Ist das in Deutschland häufig so, also ich nehme jetzt mal das Beispiel bei
Bundestagsgesetzgebungsprozessen, da wird ja auch der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte
oder die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hinzugezogen.
Ich war da selber auch schon mal Sachverständige für technische Fragen.
Auch da ist es manchmal so, dass die Gesetzesvorschläge nicht unbedingt die
Meinung des Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten übernehmen.
Und dann landet es am Ende vor Gericht in Deutschland, sehr häufig vom Bundesverfassungsgericht,
wo dann wiederum der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte oder die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte
als Sachverständige an der Urteilsfindung mitwirken. Wie ist es mit in Brüssel?
Auch da sind ja so, dass viele Gesetzgebungsverfahren am Ende beim Europäischen Gerichtshof landen.
Zwar nach Jahren, aber tritt dann dort der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte
auch wieder als Sachverständiger auf, wenn sich später darüber gestritten wird,
ob dieses Gesetz mit der EU-Charta in Einklang ist?
Ja, durchaus. Das liegt dann beim Europäischen Gerichtshof.
Der kann uns dann als Sachverständigen beiladen. Das ist auch bereits passiert.
Ich war selber persönlich da,
zum einen Fall, wo es um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zum Beispiel geht.
Da ist dann der Europäische Gerichtshof, der lädt uns dann ein und stellt Fragen,
die wir dann zu beantworten haben, erst schriftlich oder eben auch in der mündlichen
Verhandlung in Luxemburg.
Also wenn es eine gibt, wenn eine Anhörung terminiert wird. Genau.
Okay, das gehört also klassischerweise dann auch mit zu den Aufgaben.
Wird der Europäische Datenschutz-Auchtreifte auch noch von anderen Institutionen hinzugezogen?
Die jetzt nicht normalerweise zu den EU-Institutionen gehört, die er beaufsichtigt?
Inwiefern? Also wie gesagt, zu laufenden Gesetzgebungsverfahren kommt es absolut
vor, dass wir vom Europäischen Parlament beigeladen werden oder von Ausschüssen
oder von auch einzelnen Abgeordneten im Europäischen Parlament.
Und der Rat der Europäischen Union, auch der lädt ab und zu den europäischen
Datenschutzbeauftragten.
Ein, wenn es zu gewissen Punkten Stellungnahmen abzugeben sind. Das passiert.
Das sind eben halt nur die Gesetzgebungsverfahren.
Aber das ist jetzt zum Beispiel nicht so, dass ein deutscher Landesdatenschutzbeauftragter,
der sich mit irgendeiner europarechtlichen Frage oder so beschäftigen würde,
jetzt dann auch noch eine Stellungnahme einholt oder so.
Also so weit ist der Aufgabenbereich dann nicht.
Nein, wie gesagt, ja, Robert,
Also natürlich kann es sein, dass eine nationale Datenschutzbehörde einen Beschwerdefall
hat oder auch eine Firma beaufsichtigt,
die einen schwierigen Fall darstellt und Bedenken hat in der Auslegung.
Und die Auslegung muss natürlich Konsistenz über die gesamte Europäische Union
stattfinden. Und in solchen Fällen ist das schon so, dass die Datenschutzbehörde
sich an den Europäischen Datenschutzausschuss wenden kann und vorschlagen kann.
Wir haben hier ein interessantes Thema. Wir denken, das ist nicht nur relevant
für unser Land, sondern für die ganze Europäische Union und wäre es nicht toll,
hierzu eine gemeinsame Stellungnahme zu verabschieden.
Und wenn es da ein paar Freiwillige gibt, die Lust darauf haben und den Sinn sehen,
so eine Stellungnahme zu haben, dann können die das der Plenarsitzung vorschlagen
und dann kann es ein Mandat geben und dann wird da auf Europa-Ebene eine Stellungnahme erarbeitet.
Und da arbeitet natürlich dann auch der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte mit.
Nicht in jedem Einzelfall, aber auf jeden Fall haben alle die Möglichkeit,
inklusive dem europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten sich einzubringen.
Und ich denke, das ist mehr so der Mechanismus, wenn einzelne Datenschutzbehörden
Feedback von anderen haben möchten. Das ist also sehr...
Das ist der formale Weg. Dazu gibt es natürlich noch informelle Wege.
Logisch. Also die so schon mal hat man, ne?
Zum Beispiel, weil die Kollegen sich erkennen, wenn die jetzt also wissen,
jemand hatte genau schon den Fall, dann können die natürlich zum Hörer greifen
und einfach fragen, ja, könnt ihr, was habt ihr damals gemacht?
Und das geht natürlich sehr, sehr informell. Da muss man natürlich aufpassen,
dass da keine sensitiven Informationen ausgetauscht werden.
Und wenn sensitive Informationen ausgetauscht werden müssten,
gibt es natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass eine Behörde um Hilfe bittet, formell.
Und dann kann auch sensitive Informationen ausgetauscht werden,
um eben dieses gemeinsame Ziel einer konsistenten Anwendung des Datenschutzrechts zu erreichen.
Also nun gibt es ja in Deutschland, werdet ihr bestimmt wissen,
die Datenschutzkonferenz.
Da finden sich also der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte und die Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten zusammen.
Und da kommt es ja gar nicht so selten vor, die geben auch einfach Meinung ab. die veröffentlichen.
Ich würde sagen, sehr gut lesbar. Also auch für Laien, nicht jetzt unbedingt
für ein juristische Fachpublikum, sondern auch für die breite Öffentlichkeit
lesbare Stellungnahmen zu.
Oft auch aktuellen Themen oder
Datenschutzfragen, die gerade beschäftigen. Macht sowas der Datenschutzausschuss
auch, dass er sich einfach mal äußert? Thomas vielleicht?
Das macht sowohl der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss als auch der Europäische
Datenschutzbeauftragte. Ja, absolut.
Wenn wir uns äußern, zum Beispiel, ich gucke gerade auf die Webseite vom Europäischen
Datenschutzausschuss,
da sagt man eben Empfehlungen zu Rechtsgrundlagen für die Einrichtung von Nutzerkonten
auf Websites für elektronischen Geschäftsverkehr.
Das ist eine Äußerung, weil es da jetzt keinen Gesetzgebungsvorschlag gibt,
sondern es sind jetzt Sachen, wo die Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörden in Europa
finden, da müsste es mal eine Stellungnahme zu geben.
Und ähnliche Sachen machen wir eben auch. Also das ist, da sind wir wie jede
nationale Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde. Vielleicht nochmal zu dem vorherigen
Punkt. Das hat Robert ja angesprochen.
Natürlich die kollegiale Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Aufsichtsbehörden, das machen wir genauso.
Wenn es, ich sage mal, eine Anfrage aus Hessen vom hessischen Datenschutzbeauftragten geben sollte,
zu gewissen Punkten, wo sie vielleicht einen Bezug zur Europäischen Kommission
haben und jetzt wissen wollen,
warum will die Europäische Kommission von irgendeinem Unternehmen gewisse Daten
haben, dann wenden die sich an uns und wir können dann das mit der Europäischen
Kommission abklären oder den Kollegen in Hessen sagen,
ja, das ist so, weil so und so die Rechtsgrundlage so ist.
Oder wenn eben Bedarf besteht, das hat Robert ja schon erwähnt,
An Ergebnissen von Untersuchungen, die wir in Brüssel hier gemacht haben als
europäischer Datenschutzbeauftragter, Zum Beispiel im Fall Europäische Kommission und Microsoft 365.
Dann kommen die Kollegen aus den Mitgliedstaaten und können sagen,
bitte teilt mit uns auf dem Amtswege eure Erkenntnisse, damit wir davon lernen können.
Das ist gang und gäbe tägliches Brot.
Ja, Robert?
Wo wir gerade über die internationale Kooperation sprechen, möchte ich erwähnen,
dass es auch noch ein paar andere Themenbereiche gibt, die wir noch nicht angesprochen haben.
Und so ist es auch so, dass wir Software gemeinsam entwickeln,
um Audits, ganz typischerweise Webseiten oder Mobile Ads, zu vereinfachen und
dort Daten extrahieren zu können.
Und jetzt muss man natürlich sehen, dass in jeder Datenschutzbehörde die Minderheit Technologen sind.
Und um dadurch effizienter zu sein, bietet sich natürlich an,
über die Grenzen in Europa hinweg Methoden zu entwickeln, um solche komplizierten
technischen Audits durchzuführen.
Lass mich raten, da hast du auch mit zu tun, beruflich?
Das hatte ich auch in den vergangenen Jahren mit vorangetrieben, genau.
Und da ist es jetzt so, dass wir auch auf code.europa.eu Software haben,
die auch Firmen schon benutzen können, bevor die Datenschutzbehörden diese Technologie
benutzen, um Probleme zu finden.
Und diese Software wird auch von verschiedensten Datenschutzbehörden eingesetzt
und wenn es dazu Fragen gibt oder wenn man sich überlegt, was fehlt da noch,
was kann man da verbessern, da gibt es natürlich auch noch mal einen Austausch.
Und der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss hat auch Software, die entwickelt wird,
und darüber hinaus gibt es seit vielleicht zwei, drei Jahren auch jedes Jahr
wenigstens ein Workshop,
wo Techniker nach Brüssel kommen, um gemeinsam sich beizubringen,
wie man gewisse Dinge erledigt.
Stealsharing, klassisch, ja.
Genau, und das hatten die Juristen auf der...
Die hatten die Idee schon früher.
Wir haben das schon länger gemacht. Das ist sogar ein Projekt,
was nicht nur die Europäische Union betrifft, sondern auch Länder östlich.
Und da haben wir uns in der Expertengruppe für Technologiefragen gesagt,
ja, warum machen wir das nicht auch? Und wir bringen alle unsere Computer mit, sozusagen.
Und in dem Bereich ist sozusagen dieser Austausch nicht nur auf Rechtsfragen
beschränkt, sondern der findet auch statt zu technischen Fragen,
auch teilweise zu sehr praktischen.
Wie macht ihr das, wenn eine Webseite das und das hat? Wie kommt ihr an die Daten ran?
Also okay, das ist eine neuere Entwicklung, dann geht es so höher,
das hat erst zwei, drei Jahre statt 100.
Aber ich denke, das ist auch eine Entwicklung, die stattfinden muss,
denn wenn wir sehen, dass alles komplexer wird, alle Datenverarbeitungen gewinnen an Komplexität,
müssen natürlich die Datenschutzbehörden mitziehen und sich darauf einrichten,
auch mit solchen komplexen Verarbeitungsvorgängen umgehen zu können,
das analysieren zu können.
Und wenn man sieht, dass die Datenschutzbehörden häufig sehr klein sind.
In Deutschland haben wir natürlich einen Luxusfall.
Der Europäische Datenschutzausschuss hat in einem Jahresbericht veröffentlicht,
wie viele Mitarbeiter in den einzelnen Ländern mitarbeiten.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland waren das ungefähr 1000 Menschen über die verschiedenen
Landesbehörden und natürlich auf federalen Niveau hinweg verteilt.
Aber dann gibt es eben auch Länder wie Liechtenstein, wo man eher ein Dutzend
Personen ist und die müssen natürlich auch wahnsinnig viele technische Lösungen abdecken können.
Und insofern sind wir auch so ein Stück weit darauf angewiesen,
effizient zusammenzuarbeiten und uns über unsere Ansätze nicht nur zu Rechtsfragen,
sondern auch zu technischen Fragen auszutauschen.
Also ich glaube, wir haben jetzt schon mal eine ganze Menge Einblicke,
wie das so ungefähr praktisch bei euch läuft.
Ich habe jetzt noch so drei Fragen ungefähr, aber wartet, das sind schon Hammerfragen.
Die gehen so ein bisschen auf die Meta-Ebene. Also wir haben ja in den letzten
Monaten erlebt, seit der Amtseinführung, der zweiten Amtseinführung von Donald Trump,
dass sich so ein bisschen die afrikanische Datensphäre und die europäische Datensphäre
stark auseinander entwickeln.
Wir haben erlebt, dass plötzlich digitale Gesetze und Datenschutzgesetze auf
europäischer Ebene zu einem politischen Handelskampf hineingezogen werden.
Also das habt ihr ja sicherlich alle mitbekommen.
Wie seht ihr diesen Konflikt, dass man plötzlich über die Regeln,
die eben auch sehr häufig für große US-Unternehmen hier gemacht sind in Europa,
dass die plötzlich sozusagen in einer politischen Spitzenpolitik debattiert
werden, dass die von jemand so relativ irrational Handelnden wie dem US-Präsidenten
in so ganz klassische Handelskriege reingezogen werden.
Wie seht ihr diese ganzen Konflikte, die jetzt entstanden sind,
gerade in dem Feld? Vielleicht Thomas mal zuerst.
Ganz entspannt, das ist alles nichts Neues. Das gab es schon zu Zeiten der ersten
Datenschutzrichtlinie 1995.
Schon damals war absehbar, dass wenn sich Europa entscheidet,
Datenschutzvorschriften einzuführen, weil es ein Grundrecht ist,
dass das Wirtschaftsinteressen insbesondere der US-amerikanischen Konzerne betrifft.
Schon damals war sehr viel Politik im Spiel.
Das war nichts anderes, als dann die Datenschutzgrundverordnung verhandelt wurde.
Da kamen die Amerikaner schon sehr früh zur Kommission und haben vorgeschlagen,
mach das doch mal anders, mach das doch mal weniger scharf.
Und dann war es letztendlich ironischerweise die Affäre durch Edward Snowden,
der dann auf europäischer Seite dazu geführt hat, zu sagen, nee,
das geht uns jetzt zu weit, wir brauchen jetzt scharfe europäische Datenschutzvorschriften.
Also von daher ist das aus Brüsseler Sicht nichts Neues, das passiert, das ist ganz normal.
Schlecht wäre es natürlich, wenn dem Druck dann nachgegeben wird.
Wie gesagt, das kann ich mit dem europäischen Grundrechtscharakter des Datenschutzes
schlecht vereinbaren, wenn wir dann plötzlich sagen, ja wir haben jetzt Gesetze,
aber die wenden wir dann nicht an,
weil es amerikanische Konzerne sind.
Hm, also da höre ich doch nur, ja, rundsolide Entspannung. Würdest du das auch
so sehen, Robert, oder beunruhigt dich das eher?
Also ich denke gerade an einen ehemaligen Kollegen, der auch in meinem Referat
gearbeitet hat und jetzt bei der Kommission arbeitet.
Das heißt, man kennt die Menschen, die in der Kommission jetzt in der Situation
sind und diese Fälle bearbeiten.
Und ich habe da Vertrauen, dass da die richtigen Leute sitzen,
die probieren, das Beste für Europa mit den Gesetzen, die wir haben, auszurollen.
Okay, das entspannt mich auch etwas,
dass da keine Panik im europäischen oder zumindest unter den europäischen Datenschützern
die Situation so neu und aufwendig ist.
Möglicherweise ist der Präsident ein bisschen weniger berechenbar als seine
Vorgänger, aber letztlich sind die Streitereien darum,
welche Datenschutzregeln wir in Europa haben und wie sie vielleicht andere große
Unternehmen betreffen, so neu nicht. Das stimmt natürlich, so kann man es auch sehen.
Aber ich habe noch eine zweite Metafrage, die mich auch schon lange beschäftigt
eigentlich. Bin ich Deutscher?
Ich bin seit vielen Jahren vertraut mit den Datenschutzdiskussionen in Deutschland,
die auch wirklich geführt werden, die auch häufig sehr öffentlich geführt werden.
Die Chatkontrolle wäre ein Beispiel, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
aber sehr viele Beispiele.
Das heißt, die deutsche Öffentlichkeit hat oder räumt dem Grundrecht auf informationelle
Selbstbestimmung einen hohen Wert ein.
Auch die Verfahren, die beim Bundesverfassungsgericht geführt werden,
haben oft eine hohe Öffentlichkeit.
Das ist aber nicht in allen europäischen Ländern so, das werdet ihr sicherlich
viel besser wissen als ich.
Wie seht ihr diese Diskrepanzen bei der Wahrnehmung dieses Grundrechts in Europa?
Das ist nun mal nicht überall so sexy wie in Deutschland und auch in Deutschland
findet ihr auch nicht jeder sexy.
Wie überbrückt ihr diese Differenz oder wie könnt ihr damit umgehen im normalen Alltag?
Thomas vielleicht.
Das erklärt sich zum Teil aus den geschichtlichen Unterschieden,
aber auf der anderen Seite ist ja nun mal ein großer Konsens vorhanden.
Konsens im Sinne von Datenschutz existiert. Datenschutz ist auch ein Grundrecht,
insoweit ich das weiß, in allen europäischen Mitgliedstaaten.
Das ist also nicht sehr groß anders als in Deutschland. Und die Grundlage der
Zusammenarbeit, zumindest bei den Aufsichtsbehörden, ist eben die Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Und man muss auch sagen, dass Deutschland derzeit zumindest ziemlich alleine dasteht, steht,
weil die Kritik am Datenschutz, die du ja eben versucht hast anzumerken,
eigentlich eine deutsche Kritik ist. Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Diese großflächigen Spitzen gegen den Datenschutz hört man aus anderen Mitgliedstaaten nicht so.
Im Gegenteil, das wird einfach gemacht und dann wird es umgesetzt und dann ist gut so.
Du hast ja wahrscheinlich, ich frage jetzt mal Robert, oft mit den Techies aus
den anderen nationalen Aufsichtsbehörden zu tun.
Nimmst du das auch wahr, dass das sehr unterschiedlich gesehen wird beim Datenschutz
oder ist das gar nicht so unter den Techies?
Ja, jetzt sprechen wir vielleicht ein bisschen über das Profil.
Wer sind denn diese Techies? ich würde sagen, man landet unwahrscheinlich in,
Also wenn man Technologie-Expert in einer Datenschutzbehörde wird,
dann ist das häufig kein Versehen.
Dann ist das schon so, dass die Leute sich dafür wirklich sehr interessieren.
Ja, okay.
Weil die Informatiker, die Ingenieure, die haben natürlich so viele Möglichkeiten,
irgendwie Arbeit zu finden.
Und wenn sie dann in einer kleinen Datenschutzbehörde landen am Ende,
dann ist das häufig schon, weil sie sich dafür sehr interessieren. Ja, okay.
Du triffst da auf eine bestimmte Gruppe Menschen, okay.
Ich selber gehe dann auch zu den Konferenzen, auch bald wieder dem 39C3,
aber auch Konferenzen in Brüssel, Fostem kann ich zum Beispiel nennen.
Und da treffe ich dann auch Kollegen, die Technologen, Technikexperten in Datenschutzbehörden sind.
Und ich würde sagen, wir finden das Thema alle sehr, sehr wichtig.
Aber wir sind natürlich keine repräsentative Gruppe in den Mitgliedsländern.
Und jetzt ist es so, und das ist vielleicht auch noch mal eine Gelegenheit für
mich, das zu erklären, viele Datenschutzbehörden haben Probleme,
Expertise in Informatik zu rekrutieren.
Insofern möchte ich auch noch mal an alle appellieren, die selber Ingenieure
sind, Programmierer sind,
Technik mögen und sich vorstellen können,
an dieser sehr wichtigen Aufgabe der Überwachung von Firmen zum Thema Datenschutz
mitzuwirken, zu schauen, ob nicht auch ihre Datenschutzbehörde möglicherweise
offene Stellen hat und Techniker braucht.
Das ist etwas sehr Wichtiges natürlich, weil mit der technischen Expertise,
Expertise allgemein, fällt natürlich oder gewinnt natürlich die Effizienz jeder Anschlussbehörde.
Also ein Aufruf, einem abhält quasi.
Ja, und auch die Leute, die aus...
Die dann entsandt werden zu diesen Meetings in Brüssel, mögen sie jetzt nur
in Person sein oder online, da sind natürlich Leute, die da schon Herzblut haben und wirklich,
ja nicht nur ein professionelles, vielleicht auch teilweise ein persönliches Interesse haben,
dort einen guten Kompromiss zu finden.
Und ja, die Frage, die du vorher gestellt hast, da bin ich froh,
dass du nicht noch mich nochmal fragst, weil wir sind natürlich Beamte und ich
mache da eine klare Unterscheidung. Und für mich ist das eben keine Politik.
Und wenn es nun um diese großen Fragen gibt, dann sind das Fragen,
das muss die Kommission klären, das können die Parlamente diskutieren.
Die Datenschutzbehörden müssen also vorsichtig sein, weil sie eben nicht da
sind, die Gesetze in Frage zu stellen.
Wir setzen die Gesetze um, dann gibt es natürlich gewisse Entscheidungen.
Das sage ich als Spielräume. Das bedeutet, auch Datenschutzbehörden können sagen,
wenn ihr jetzt ISIS-Gesetz erlässt, dann wäre das aber doch im Konflikt mit diesem anderen Gesetz.
Also insofern können die sich schon dazu äußern.
Aber ansonsten müssen wir natürlich neutral bleiben und als Verwaltung professionell
mit jeder Regierung zusammenarbeiten, die gebildet wurde.
Und das gilt nicht nur für das europäische Niveau, sondern natürlich auch für die Mitgliedsländer.
Na gut, dann biege ich jetzt so die Zielgerade ein und stelle euch noch eine
letzte Frage und beginne mal mit dir, Robert, diesmal.
Nun, wenn man in so einer Behörde arbeitet und seinen Alltag hat,
dann fällt damit vielleicht nicht so auf, aber wenn man ein bisschen länger
schon drin ist, dann schält man sich oft oder man bemerkt, dass es bestimmte Defizite gibt.
Gibt es was, was du dir für den europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten für die
Zukunft wünschen würdest, was echt notwendig wäre oder was die Effizienz oder
die Qualität der Arbeit verbessern würde?
Dann ist hier sozusagen dein Weihnachtswunsch.
Wir kommen erst im Januar raus, aber wir sind ja noch vor Weihnachten.
Dann kannst du dich jetzt anbringen.
Also die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre habe ich beim europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten
die Funktion als Leiter der Unterabteilung Digital Transformation inne gehabt.
Und da habe ich natürlich Zeit und auch die Aufgabe, mir über Verbesserungen Gedanken zu machen.
Und ich denke, meine Kritik ist gar nicht so spezifisch für Datenschutzbehörden,
aber eher für Behörden im Allgemeinen.
Und ich habe, bevor ich beim Datenschutzbeauftrag angefangen habe, da war ich Doktorand,
habe auch Software entwickelt und wir haben richtig gute Tools,
um Software zu entwickeln und das auch gemeinsam zu entwickeln.
Und ich muss sagen, was ich so von manchen Datenschutzbehörden und Mitgliedsländern
gesehen habe, ist der EDPS sicherlich im guten Mittelfeld.
Wir hatten schon sehr früh eine digitale Akte.
Das hat natürlich unheimliche Vorteile gehabt während der Corona-Pandemie.
Aber ich denke, generell kann man da noch viel mehr durch Automatisierung von Prozessen erreichen.
Ich wünsche mir, dass wir Dashboards haben, um Fallmanagement zu machen und
zwar nicht jedes Land einzeln, sondern am besten eines, was für alle Datenschutzbehörden
funktionieren würde und sowas haben wir momentan nicht.
Alleine der Prozess, Leute Zugriff zu dem gemeinsamen Wiki auf EDSA-Ebene zu
bringen, ist irritierend für jeden, der Informatik studiert hat.
Und ich glaube aber, wie ich sagte, dass das nicht etwas ist,
worunter nur Datenschutzbehörden leiden, sondern das ist generell die Verwaltung.
Und man sieht, wie auch Deutschland Schwierigkeiten hat, Digitalisierung zu machen.
Und es ist natürlich mit dem föderalen Konzept vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber natürlich gibt es darüber nach doch das europäische Niveau und dadurch
hat man nochmal eine Komplexitätsebene mehr. Und viele Dinge...
Gerade auch beim Datenschutzrecht. Also es sind keine reinen nationalen Fälle
mehr. Da geht es um Facebook, da geht es um X.
Das sind alles Fälle, die gerne auch mal das europäische Niveau erreichen können.
Und was ich mir wünschen würde, dass es eine digitale Strategie gibt,
die nicht nur national denkt, sondern die auch europäisch denkt.
Und ich denke, da fehlt es uns an vielen Standardisierungsprozessen.
Und das ist auch sehr schwer, da was in Gang zu bringen, Weil dann auch die
Datenschutzbehörden sagen,
ja, eigentlich ist ja unser Land dafür zuständig und wir haben hier nur ganz
wenige Informatiker und wir sind froh, wenn die uns mit unseren Audits helfen.
Und das Geld ist natürlich auch knapp in den Behörden. Insofern ist jetzt nicht
klar, wie das ich demnächst verbessern könnte.
Oh, da hättest du eine lange Wunschliste, ich sehe.
Und da kann, glaube ich, jeder Informatiker
in der Datenschutzbehörde sehr passioniert lange darüber reden,
wie diese Situation nicht so perfekt ist und wie man viel mehr noch lernen könnte
von den Prozessen, die wir in der Informatik haben, zur Zusammenarbeit und da
es auch Anwendungsmöglichkeiten finden würde,
so auch die Prozesse in Datenschutzbehörden, aber auch über Datenschutzbehörden hinweg zu entwickeln.
Okay. Jetzt ist vielleicht eine Antwort, die ist ein bisschen nerdy.
Das ist eine gewisse technologische Brille, die man auf diese Prozesse hat.
Ich vermute mal, dass bei Thomas die Antwort, was er sich für die Zukunft wünschen
würde, ein bisschen anders ausfiehle. Oder etwa nicht?
Ich würde mich da eigentlich eher dem Robert anschließen, denn warum?
Natürlich hat eine Behörde ein Amt, wie der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte,
hat nie genug Mitarbeiter und hat nie genug Geld.
Das wird sich aber in absehbarer Zeit, soweit ich das sehe, auch nicht ändern.
Aber was in der Tat, was uns gut zu Gesicht stände, wäre, was Robert gesagt
hat, bessere Automatisierung von Prozessen.
Nur als ein Beispiel.
Wir, habe ich ja bereits gesagt, wir bearbeiten natürlich auch Eingaben und
Beschwerden von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern.
Und wir sehen gerade in der letzten Zeit eine 140-prozentige Steigerung dieser
Beschwerden auf uns zukommen.
Warum? Weil natürlich die Leute, die sich beschweren,
zu KI greifen und sagen, schreib mir mal jetzt eine Beschwerde gegen die Europäische
Kommission, sodass ich das direkt an einen europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten schicken kann.
Und da müssen wir hingehen. Wir brauchen Waffengleichheit, um das mal so zu sagen.
Wir müssen auch praktisch KI-gestützte Anwendungen zur Verfügung haben,
um vielleicht dann auch besser und effizienter arbeiten zu können.
Vielleicht auch noch als nette Zugabe, als Herausforderung für uns.
Wir sind ja nun auch gleichzeitig Aufsichtsbehörde für KI-Systeme von den europäischen Organen.
Das heißt, wir haben eine Doppelaufgabe, nicht nur Datenschützer,
sondern eben auch KI-Aufsicht.
Und auch da sehe ich die Notwendigkeit, dass wir dann eben die zugrunde liegende
Technik verstehen und auch Kolleginnen und Kollegen dafür einstellen,
die das dann beaufsichtigen können.
Dann können wir nur hoffen, dass der Weihnachtsmann eure Wunschliste bekommen hat.
Aber es ist, ja klar, ich kann verstehen, gerade bei dieser Fülle an Anfragen,
dass man sich natürlich da mehr technische Automatisierung wünscht. Na klar.
Meine Herren, es hat mich sehr gefreut, mit euch zu sprechen.
Ich glaube, es war ganz interessant zu sehen, wie so ein Arbeitsablauf in so
einem Amt, was in Deutschland nicht so richtig doll bekannt ist,
zumindest was man da so macht und was so die Aufgaben sind, da mal ein paar Ähmliche zu kriegen.
Ich fand auch die pragmatische Wunschliste, die ihr habt, eigentlich am Ende sehr schön.
Und vielleicht würde ich als Letztes noch mal sagen wollen, wenn sich jemand
interessiert für diese Behörde, vielleicht könnt ihr doch sagen,
Wo kriegt man am ehesten schlaue Informationen?
Habt ihr ein Angebot für Menschen, die sich für den europäischen Datenschutz
beauftragen, für den Ausschuss interessieren, wo man sich noch Informationen herholen kann?
Dann könnt ihr die jetzt noch droppen. Thomas?
Auf jeden Fall. Auf unsere Homepage gehen, edps.europa.eu.
Da findet man alles, was das Herz begehrt, Insbesondere auch kurz und knappe
Informationen zu dem, was wir machen und auch zur Technik und zu neuen Technologien,
was vielleicht für den einen oder anderen interessant ist.
Aber eben auch unsere Entscheidungen.
Podcasts gibt es auch, Robert.
Ja, genau. Natürlich ist unser erstes Medium die Schriftform.
Aber der EDPS möchte natürlich modern sein und auch viele Menschen erreichen,
auch wenn die zum Beispiel gerade unterwegs sind und aber einen Podcast hören möchten.
Und deswegen gibt es sozusagen die Vertonung in Gesprächsform von einigen unserer
Arbeiten auch auf unserer Webseite.
Habt ihr schon mal an den Podcast mitgewirkt selber? Ihr beide?
Ich selber noch nicht, nein. Ich mag Podcasting auch gar nicht so gerne.
Doch.
Und du, Thomas?
Ich habe ein Gespräch geführt, aber nicht im Podcast, sondern mit Video.
Ja, okay.
Aber ich möchte noch eine weitere Möglichkeit erwähnen, wie man uns erfolgen kann.
Und zwar hat der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte auch ein Mastodon-Account.
Uh, Fetty Wurst.
Genau, und da kann man uns auch finden. Ich glaube, unser Handle ist edps.social.edps.eu.
Das verlinken wir dann vielleicht, das weiß ich jetzt nicht,
ob sich das alle merken können.
Auf jeden Fall möchte ich mich sehr bedanken für die Zeit, die ihr euch genommen
habt und für die Einblicke, die ihr gegeben habt.
Und ich hoffe, wer sich weiter dafür interessiert, kann die Informationsangebote annehmen.
Und ich bedanke mich bei Thomas und bei Robert und bei allen Hörern und Hörern. Tschüss.